buzzie first of all let me just say to
you I love you first I love you too and
Leslie West is my hero he was the first
guy I wrote this on one of his albums he
asked me to write a few words but he was
one of the first guys that I ever you
know in rock'n'roll who I really related
to I thought his band mountain was
incredible when they came on the scene I
got to tell you something and this is my
point
having Leslie on today as we make our
move to satellite you are my first guest
that I want to do this with I want to
say to you thank you for all the years
of coming in always appearing live with
us always playing playing for us my
pleasure man because you are absolutely
my hero and this is the next step I mean
you just thank you right but I want you
to know that this show appreciates you I
personally appreciate you in the music
you've given the world and you're a
great guy you're a survivor and I love
that and you're a really good guy good
guy to hang with and you and this show
appreciates all the contributions you've
made over the years I think this song is
very fitting bye next down this mountain
does Dylan I picked some great songs and
did some rearranging all right
[Music]
Pam in a roads must a man long down
Bevo be calling me
[Music]
how many seas must a wrapped-up sail
before she sleeps in the same
[Music]
how many time most cannonballs fly
he for the forever
the intern my friend with the intern
blowing
[Music]
we have a mouth
blah
[Music]
the answer isn't bombing
[Music]
good enough I love you man I love you I
love you that's great you always give me
the chills when you play and sing man
and not too many people can do that you
are this you are awesome